[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour ce
nouveau numéro du cetud culture et tout
cuir tout de suite le sommaire de ce
mercredi 7 décembre
l'opéra rock starmania inspire toujours
des étudiants de l'université versailles
saint quentin chanteur on lit titre
imaginé par luc plamondon et michel
berger
le baron de münchhausen avait lardons
jolivet ses aventures la troupe suisse
am stram gram on a fait une pièce
familiale et nous partirons en irlande
avec child jack charlie et les habitants
du comté de kerry leur histoire était à
découvrir au théâtre espace coluche de
plaisir quand on arrive en ville
sos d'un terrien en détresse ou encore
la chanson de ziggy et plus de 40 ans
connaissent tous ces champs sont du
moins les fans de comédies musicales en
1978 débarqué sur scène l'opéra rock
starmania créée par luc plamondon et
michel berger
des étudiants de l'université versailles
saint quentin ont décidé de la jouer à
leur tour nous avons assisté à une de
leur dernière représentation
les images sont signées nicolas
d'anglais canton dont le tranquille dans
les banlieues dortoirs voit les étoiles
noires décembre sur est
ils n'étaient pas nés dans les années
soixante dix et pourtant ces étudiants
ont choisi de reprendre sur scène
starmania l'opéra rock de luc plamondon
et michel berger
je suis une fan inconditionnelle de
michel berger et france gall et je sais
pas je pense que c'était un coup de
foudre ils écouteront les explique pas
je les personnaliser parce qu'on a pris
la version la deuxième version donc
celle de 89 mais j'ai mis des des
chansons de la version de 78 auditions
en septembre répétitions chaque semaine
un quotidien partagé entre cours et
comédie musicale ils sont tous étudiants
à l'université versailles saint quentin
c'était très intensif il fallait bien
connaître bien connaître les chansons
après c'est surtout le jouer le
personnage qui est un peu compliqué
surtout quand on doit se mettre dans la
peau d'un homme sac c'est pas facile
mais après à force de travail et à
fournir des efforts tout c'est quelque
chose que je connais pas du tout et où
ce que davantage me perfectionner
mais ça me plaît bien c'est je trouve ça
amusant il ya 40 ans starmania lancé les
carrières de france gall et daniel
balavoine
ces étudiants connaîtront eux leur
première scène le 9 décembre
ziggy johnny rockfort et crystal n'ont
pas pris une ride
[Musique]
qui a dit que le mensonge et été mauvais
le baron de münchausen en a fait un art
il comptait des aventures toutes plus
rocambolesques les unes que les autres
un destin qui a inspiré rudolph erich
raspe et gottfried auguste burger le
théâtre suisse am stram gram a choisi de
le mettre en scène un peu plus d'une
heure de folie
à découvrir sur la scène du théâtre
national de saint quentin en yvelines
le rocher de gibraltar on regardait se
séparer une fille et un garçon michals n
était un baron un officier au service de
la russie un homme célèbre pour ses
affabulations pour la pièce l'auteur luc
rémois un fils qui vit des aventures
auquel il ne croyait pas toute l'idée de
ce spectacle c'est de faire valoir de
donner sa valeur à l'imaginaire de dire
que bien sûr on est dans un monde très
cartésien 2 et 2 font toujours quatre
alors chez minh châu dôc ne savez jamais
4 et donc c'est toute l'idée est là
c'est de faire en sorte de donner à
entendre et à rendre compte de
d'espacement taux qui sont pas seulement
notre monde quotidien
la pièce de fabrice melquiot mail
mapping et composition d'acteur et
plonge le spectateur dans un imaginaire
un moment de folie et sans un peu cinglé
mais en même temps ils sont cinglés
comme comme tout un chacun l'est où
devrait se permettre de la être en tout
cas alors évidemment on vient beaucoup
on peut parler beaucoup de l'enfance se
dire que l'on peut dire que les enfants
cette capacité de s'ennuyer pi2
l'instant la presse retrouve au lieu
d'un champ de bataille et puis me mets
faire les bruits et c'est vraiment
génial mais je pense qu'en tant
qu'adulte
quand on se donne la possibilité soit de
rejouer avec des enfants soient des tout
seul c'est de faire pareil on est assez
content et ça nous fait beaucoup de bien
avec en toile de fond une relation
père-fils munchhausen fourmis davanture
à voir en famille de 7 à 77 ans
on continue avec le théâtre mais a
plaisir à cette fois jeudi 1er décembre
le théâtre espace coluche emmener ses
spectateurs en irlande dans le comté de
kerry s'installe une superproduction
hollywoodienne deux mondes complètement
différents qui se retrouvent bouleversé
deux acteurs sur scène eric métayer et
elrik thomas ce jeudi jacques est
charlie de traînes savates irlandais
elrik thomas eric métayer lors donne
corps à huer à cet autre personnage à
chacun pour prépare c'est surtout d'une
grosse technicité de deux rapports entre
nous on se connaît tellement que voilà
et surtout un travail qu'on connaissait
aussi qu'il travaille dur rien du vide
de créer un espace avec simplement
l'imaginaire donc ce travail assez
simplement pas montrer que c'est une
précision nous de très très forte
on est très très précis dans ce qu'on
fait mais faut pas que ça se voit faut
que ça passe pour de l'improvisation
alors que ça ne l'est pas une quinzaine
de personnages pour retracer la vie des
habitants du comté de kerry des
irlandais dont le quotidien est
bouleversé par l'arrivée d'une équipe de
tournage des cailloux plein les poches
c'est le retour sur scène d'une pièce
nommée cinq fois aux molières en 2004
c'est très agréable à jouer puis en plus
on se connaît très très bien le plaisir
à jouer ensemble un plaisir un plaisir
voilà même toujours une bague forêt
c'est moi ça ça que j'adore chez lui pas
passé par papa hawks à la wii on prend
plaisir parce que on est toujours à la
recherche de du frémissement de l'oeil
de l'autre que moi je passe mon temps à
essayer de chercher une connerie pour le
faire rire et que oui c'est la même
chose avec son rythme effréné cette
pièce est plus qu'une simple comédie
elle questionne aussi sur des sujets
graal c'est là son tour de force
il veut amener un plus pour les amateurs
de musique et direction l'auditorium
deux trappes marianne piketty au violon
xavier philippe au violoncelle et eric
le sage au piano trois solistes de
lavilledieu se retrouvent pour jouer
deux trios du célèbre compositeur
autrichien autrichien franz schubert ça
se passe le 10 décembre à 18 heures on
écoute marianne piketty qui est aussi la
directrice artistique des solistes
j'ai des oeuvres les dernières oeuvres
de schubert qui en pleine maturité en
pleine possession de son langage et puis
moi ce que j'adore dans son verre ce
qu'on adore tous et il a une facilité à
écrire un génie de la ligne mélodique
une facilité à développer en fait à nous
faire voyager et développer ses lignes
mélodiques
[Musique]
cette semaine on pas aux yeux d'elsa la
scène la salle de cinéma de saint cyr
l'école
bertrand pin et vous propose un
rendez-vous pour petits et grands pour
les gouttes
le coup de coeur des yeux d'elsa cette
semaine c'est un programme de courts
métrages qui s'appelle jeu de lune
programme de courts métrages qui a été
préparé par le festival ciné junior en
2016 et que nous accueillons la semaine
prochaine à partir du mercredi 14
décembre et le mercredi 14 décembre il
sera présenté dans une séance très
particulière puisqu'il sera accompagné
de compte dit dans la salle entre les
films de manière à faire ce se promener
les films l'un avec l'autre affaire
s'associer les films l'un avec l'autre
notre animatrice mariée mais vous vous
présentera à chacun des films par des
petits contes aussi autour des
thématiques de la lune
donc c'est vraiment un moment très
adapté aux tout petits dès 3 4 ans il ya
un goûter qui sera proposé à l'arrivée
dans la salle on pourra passer un vrai
bon moment en famille avec les plus
petits et les plus grands qui prendront
évidemment du plaisir à découvrir ces
courts métrages et a passé du temps avec
une une conteuse dans la salle de cinéma
les yeux d'elsa ce sera donc le mercredi
14 décembre à 16h30
et c'est un tarif unique de 3 euros 50
pour tout le monde à très bientôt
[Musique]
et comme chaque semaine quelques rendez
vous à noter dans vos agendas
c'est la dernière ligne droite pour
notre jeu concours vous avez jusqu'au 12
décembre pour tenter de remporter des
places pour le spectacle de bernard
pivot
l'animateur raconte l'histoire d'un
écrivain dévoré par les mots et on
regarde un extrait en rentrant de
l'école puis du collège j'aimais
beaucoup joué avec mon copain petit
larousse
les dictionnaires sont les meilleures
agences de voyages du monde
ma première déclaration d'amour a été
pour henriette je lui ai dit henriette
je t'aime
elle m'a regardé étonné elle m'a dit
mais mais tu ne pourrais pas trouvé une
formule un peu plus original et pour
gagner ces places cette direction la
page facebook de tv fil 78
le mentalisme est célèbre grâce à la
série du même nom la série américaine
fabien olicard lui est français il est
un l'une de ces personnes capables par
l'observation et l'analyse de dresser le
portrait de son interlocuteur pour le
voir sur scène direction les
clayes-sous-bois samedi des sens il sera
sur la scène de l'espace l'espace à
philippe noiret un dernier rendez vous
et c'est à la ferme de bel ébat à
guyancourt pianiste au logis symphonique
où le concert d'un pianiste devenu fou
simon fâche mélange tout et c'est à
découvrir le samedi 10 décembre regardez
cet extrait
à partir du moment où tout le monde
confond pro colao
avec marianne backes
e
au bout faire ce qu'on veut le cetud
culture est maintenant terminée je vous
remercie de nous avoir suivis vous
pouvez le regarder à nouveau en replay
sur le site de tv fil 78 points comme je
vous dis à mercredi prochain
[Musique]